Ah, sorry for taking so long.
Sorry.
I think that's like the longest waiting screen I've ever had.
I'm so sorry.
Hello everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
I forgot my controller.
There we go.
That... OK.
It was connecting, but it made the disconnect noise.
That's so funny.
That's so quirky.
12 months of winter!
Thank you!
One year as a Wisp.
Wow.
I have a question.
Do you guys think I should like get an official...
Because I'm getting... I'm getting badges for some of the other months.
I'm getting them made.
But do you want me to get one for one year too?
Or an official like badge?
Or should I... I feel like you can't even read the one that I drew.
Yes?
Like, so change that.
Will it still be number one Jorker?
Is that what it says?
Because I wrote Jorker and then I wrote something else, no?
It's funnier this way.
Yeah, all the rest will be nice and shiny and look good and then this one will be ugly.
Hold on, I have it.
Hold on, I have it saved.
I think I was looking at it just the other day.
Sorry, when I click out of the game the audio stops.
What the... I was like, what's tickling my face?
There's a hair on my mic.
Wait, wait, one second.
Where did I... Oh I found it.
Oh it says...
Number one the Jorker.
Oh you're right.
Yeah, who's hair?
Probably from my cat ears.
I wore these yesterday on Doki stream and then I just slept in them.
I didn't even take them off.
So...
Yeah, I have them on again.
I was like, well it doesn't really match Devil May Cry, but it's kind of fun.
It's a little extra bonus for watching the stream.
Kitty may cry.
Queen never cry.
It's not popular anymore.
Gosh, memes come and go so quickly nowadays, huh Koharu?
I have my Koharu plushie... puppet.
I almost said plushie.
My Koharu plush... no, I almost said it again.
Puppet right here.
I've been taking her everywhere like she's my child.
I love her.
I got my friend... she did an order like it's for the... it's not Yostar I don't think.
I don't think that does like the Chinese store, but like in China they get different Blue Archive merch and they had like a whole bunch of Koharu things and so she helped do an order for me to get Koharu.
The puppet is so cute.
Yes!
If you didn't see it, it's on my Twitter, but yeah, I think since Nexon... that would make sense, right?
Did you see the news about Blue Archive coming to Steam?
I did see that.
I did!
First I whip it out, then I thrust it.
Wait, full voiced?
I did not see that.
You think my mobile... you think I'll be able to log in, right?
Who's your favorite DMC character besides Dante?
Mine is Lady.
I think Nero, I like him a lot.
I like Nero.
Full voice?
That's crazy.
One full year of maker.
It's super cute until the puppet starts talking back.
God, I wish!
Koharu, say something!
Speak to me!
Say something right now!
Do the performance test.
Let's see how many frames you got.
What is this?
I don't even know what the performance test is.
BT!
Florida man.
Thank you for 12 months.
Thank you.
Death penalty.
I'm thinking more about Virgil.
That suits your name, Virgil.
It's a video, basically.
Oh, really?
Rolling for idols next week?
We're saving for another banner.
I feel like I should save for swimsuit Annika.
Because I really want her.
Why are my frames dropping?
They're dropping like flies!
I wonder...
The time has come and so have I!
I really hope you've been enjoying these games.
I'm playing them myself right now.
So I don't really want to be spoiled.
Have fun!
Oh, they're still dropping!
It looks so smooth though, no?
Huh?
I guess if you wanted to just listen to the song...
Noisy creatures around here!
You!
Stupid dog!
The flag is so fast!
It really is!
Look at it zooming!
This is so funny.
They're just causing chaos in the streets.
How long does this go for?
Until the song is over?
I
wonder if I wasn't running OBS and Vtube Studio...
What it would be like, you know?
I wonder how much it would be then.
Get me out of here!
Escape!
Devil may cry...
I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit though.
Well, I only got up to 300 at my top.
Powerful Minto machine.
It's gotta be powerful though, no?
I gotta have a good computer.
It's the job!
I think 400 plus FPS is sufficient.
That's what happens when you play a game and it's just like...
What FPS limit do you want?
And it says unlimited.
Let your computer be free!
Wait, did I miss?
Wait, did you say that Hayden?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Happy birthday to me!
I feel like such a jerk.
I didn't even read.
Or I saw it.
I'm so sorry.
I'm such a jerk.
My time is... Wait, I think it just... Sorry.
I was up so late last night.
So I'm a little slow today.
I'm a little slow today.
Yes!
Hayden, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Hayden.
Happy birthday!
I try not to run on autopilot during stream because...
I could always just see a super chat and be like, thanks for the super chat!
And not read it and not process what it says or anything and just be like, thanks!
But I don't want to be... I want to read your message.
But I felt like I was just on autopilot just then.
That's so freaky.
I've never been like that before.
You know when you get on autopilot when you're driving your car and you're just going through the motions?
Freaky, freaky, freaky.
I don't like it.
I don't like that that just happened to me.
I feel freaky, but in a bad way.
Freaky derogatory.
I went on autopilot today at work.
Yeah, but that's understandable, no?
Severin's real!
Who was I talking to?
This might be a little too like...
I won't mention the other person just in case they don't want to...
How do you say?
Actually, I mentioned it in the business...
Business Insider.
It might be a little too like fourth WALL-E, so sorry.
I've never seen that movie, WALL-E.
Was it Mogu?
How do you know what I'm talking about, Radix?
Who else other than Mogu?
Well yeah, Mogu was...
Actually, I haven't talked to so many people about Severin's.
But how like...
Kind of...
Like I'm an innie, you guys.
It's kind of freaky.
Wait, if I possessed you, would I be your innie?
Wait...
I wonder if that's how it would work.
lol Oh!
I pressed the wrong button.
You know, it's fine.
McPain must do that to me a lot.
Brandon, I hope you heal up soon, man.
I feel so bad.
Linking and trying to remember the last two miles.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes!
Actually though...
Also, Nicholas, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Clockwork, welcome back.
And BinaryGhost, welcome back!
Your DMC playthrough reminded me of just...
How much I love this franchise.
I ended up buying DMC 1 through 5 on my PC.
I can't wait for you to play DMC 5!
Thanks, Waterboy!
I've heard that DMC 5 might be my favorite one.
I think that's like the fan favorite, no?
Which is kind of crazy.
That like...
The last game of the series is the most...
Like...
I don't know.
This peak, it's amazing.
Is it...
I guess it's like...
That's so rare where they like...
Where a game series will not only...
Implement quality of life changes...
But then also have a good story.
So...
Especially that late in the series.
Like 5 games later.
That's so...
That's so impressive.
DMC 6 Cope.
Who knows?
Maybe...
That will be my new Tomodachi life too.
Thank you so much, you're so sweet.
No, I feel like that's what anybody would say, no?
Are you gonna play DMC?
I don't know yet.
We'll see how much I'm thirsting for more Devil May Cry content.
I might get the end of 5 and be like...
I have to play it, you know?
I mean, I played...
I played 2.
Might as well, huh?
It's a very long though.
It's a very long.
Have you watched the DMC Netflix show?
No, I haven't.
I know it's set in a different...
Like, timeline, universe...
Type of dealio, but...
I'm waiting to finish the games before I watch the animes.
Both of them.
DMC is a much better game than 2 for what it's worth.
Ah, okay.
Well, that's good to know at least.
That's good to know at least.
Please use the Sparda skin.
Oh!
Mr. Orange, I was going to.
Because I wanted to match the thumbnail.
But I won't be disappointed.
Okay.
I'm excited then.
I'm excited.
Both DMC anime are okay.
And worth watching once.
I feel like...
I don't know, I know that some people have mixed opinions on the new one.
But probably because...
Some people want to see the games being animated.
But then if they go off on their own timeline...
It's kind of, you know...
DMC isn't as bad as 2.
They made a lot of updates that fix a lot of the gameplay problems at launch.
I see.
DMC Devil May Cry is good.
Different, but good.
Okay.
See, I've always heard that it was bad.
Now I don't know what to believe.
So many people are saying it's good.
Is that a lie too?
Hello Mito.
Congrats on 350k.
Can I pet that kitty Mito?
No pet.
I'm matching with Koharu right now.
Anyway.
Should we start?
We have like 4 missions I believe it was.
17, 18, 19, 20.
I think.
And...
I'll do my best...
To get through them in a reasonable amount of time.
Don't play on PC.
Sad, I remember...
Yeah, the ports for 1 through 3 were not so great for PC either.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Pet, pet, pet, pet, pet.
5 is fine on the PC.
I did hear that too.
Actually, I think I...
Hold on, let me see.
Devil may cry.
I do own the...
I actually bought the HD collection for PC.
Before I realized.
I think it was like a big...
There was a big sale.
And so I bought all of them at once.
And then I heard that the port for PC...
For the HD collection...
Was not good.
So...
But that's okay.
My job is ending so I'm ordering some wacky pizza.
It's Friday.
It is Friday.
Yeah, it's Friday.
Friday is pizza day.
And what better game to play...
Wait, what better game to eat pizza with than devil may cry?
Too late to return it?
Actually...
I might...
Steam doesn't have like a...
I know they have like an app...
Like if you play for more than two hours...
You can't return it, but...
Do they have a date of return?
Because I bought it so long ago.
Two weeks.
Ah, yeah.
No way.
It's okay though.
Devil may cry.
I'm waiting for my tears.
Unfortunate, but understandable.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's all good.
Golly.
This outfit is so silly.
Are we really gonna finish up the game in this outfit?
Pirate, do you...
Do you...
Do you change the number of fives every time?
I feel like it's grown.
I mean, I've made it longer, but...
I feel like it's gotten longer.
Packed and tried to leave on autopilot.
That was pretty embarrassing.
You're going downtown.
Wow.
You're a criminal.
Yeah, we're matching the thumbnail.
We're matching the thumbnail.
Chatter is admitting to a felony.
It wouldn't be a felon...
Wait.
A felony is like a big, big crime, no?
A felony would be like if you stole thousands of dollars worth of groceries, no?
Or is a felony also a small crime?
I paid for it.
Yeah, with jail time.
Felony is big crimes, yeah.
Yeah, so...
Stole one dozen eggs.
Yeah, I paid for it.
Five years in the slammer.
In California, a felony is a serious criminal offense punishable by death or imprisonment in state prison for more than one year.
Wow.
What's a...
What's like a small crime, then?
Small crime versus big crime.
Big crime...
Murder.
Misdemeanor.
So if I punch someone, is that a misdemeanor?
Jaywalking?
I see.
Where does tax evasion fall?
I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding!
Commit?
No!
It's definitely a felony.
My FBI agent...
Hold on, let me tell my phone this.
I did not commit tax evasion.
Commit?
Sometimes if I say something...
Like, kind of out there...
I'll...
Like, maybe I'm just...
I'm just, you know...
I'm just joking!
I have to remind my FBI agent in my phone.
I'll be like...
Or if I really want something to happen, I'll be like...
What's an example?
For example...
I don't know.
I felt like cooking up a DMC Dante mix.
Wait!
Jinzo fire sparta my dad.
Yeah!
Double, double trigger.
Purple, blue orb.
Wacky woohoo.
Pizza man!
Did I get the cadence right?
Why purple and blue orb though?
Blorb, blorb, blorb.
Okay, I'm stalling.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh!
This is where we did the test!
We're doing another performance test everybody.
Regain possession of Yamato.
Yamato.
Rorb erasure.
Yeah, we have to include all rorbs maybe.
I mean all orbs.
Made it home just in time.
Examito.
Yay!
Thank you!
Tomato.
Yamato.
Tomato, Yamato.
That awkward moment when you work for the IRS and your OSHI starts talking about tax evasion.
I...
It wasn't... I didn't commit any crime.
Am I...
I literally, literally texted my tax person like right before stream.
My tax person is a real, real person.
And not someone that said that they would get me out of doing my taxes.
Oh no, she sounds guilty.
I've never been guilty ever.
He's Ocelot.
Yeah, Ocelot's doing my taxes for me.
Oh gosh, I'm gonna have to get all reacquainted.
Ah...
It's okay, I haven't done mine in like a decade, boss.
In Minecraft.
Is your tax person in the room with us right now?
I hope not.
I hope she's not watching.
Okay, hold on.
We got our stingers.
We've got our stinger tool.
Okay.
Lucifer.
This is the one I just got.
This is the one that I haven't used yet.
Lucifer.
Yes, yes, yes.
I want to test him.
My guns.
Wait, I think I just have the charge.
I don't have that.
I did not buy that.
Pandora, this thing is hard.
Wow, holding X and then we circle around.
Styles.
We have...
Just jumping around.
Sword Master.
Gunslinger.
What is this?
Where did I buy this?
Minto probably has enough dependents to claim from the karaoke stream tonight.
What do you mean dependents?
Oh, babies.
Oh, I don't use royal guard.
I'm sorry.
I know people are going to flame me.
Trigger heart.
Sorry, I'm just going through everything again.
I'm so slow today.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I feel like I've been saying that a lot lately, but...
Today I just didn't get much sleep.
I'm sorry.
It's okay, no royal guard.
Thank you.
Autopilot Minto.
Again, I've never been like that before.
That was so freaky.
Freaky, freaky.
Freaky derogatory.
I need to get one more lore fragment.
Let's just go into it.
See what happens.
It's been a long week, huh boys?
Sorry the outfit is so funny.
Is this it?
This?
Dante dripped out.
Did you guys see that?
That clip of the guy who directed the new Netflix anime.
And he was at like some wrestling event.
And it was just like...
This is the guy.
Cosplaying Dante from Devil May Cry.
The Netflix series.
No one cheers.
No one boos.
It was like...
It was like the most quiet I've ever seen a WWE audience.
Literally ever.
Boys are awkward, huh?
Alright, hold on.
Oh my goodness.
Big.
What is this?
Oh.
Ah!
You're telling me Nero needs to break that, huh?
Okay, well that guy is somewhere.
Where the hell do I go in here?
What?
There's like...Oh, I think I...
Wait, do I press this?
No?
What am I on right now?
Swordmaster, okay.
I guess I go this way.
Wait, this is where I get...
Wait.
Down?
Oh, I see it.
I didn't even notice.
Ah!
Money.
Already lost.
Today is gonna be rough, you guys.
Today might be a little rough.
Come out everybody.
I want to test my new toys.
Over here.
Someone will come out.
Hello?
Why is it...Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Wow!
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wow.
Am I killing them?
I can't tell.
Yah!
Very slowly.
That's kind of fun though.
Interesting.
Oh, ouch.
Okay.
Interesting.
I think I...I don't think I get it.
But it's interesting.
For sure.
Oh, no.
How do I make them explode?
Do I have to do that manually?
What the hell was that?
It's timed.
Okay.
Oh!
Back and wide?
Oh, ouch.
Hold on.
Oh, I can't aim it very well though.
I still haven't even killed this Jester man.
This is so tricky.
You have to aim it really well.
What if I do this?
Okay, hold on.
What the hell is that?
I'm confused what's going on.
This is a strange...
Lucifer is weird, you guys.
I don't know if I like it.
Oh, shoot.
I'm acupuncturing them.
He's got some in his head.
Oh, dang it.
I missed.
I don't know if I like it.
Is this like kind of slow?
Oh, my god.
Golly.
Come here.
Stupid.
Oh,
I thought I would have dodged that.
Oh, my god.
These guys are so...
Lucifer is known to be one of the most complicated weapons in the franchise.
I don't know if I like it very much.
I feel like they give it to you too late game...
to figure out how to use it properly.
Alaric, thank you.
Hey, Pocktie, welcome back.
Thank you.
You're supposed to play TMC games multiple times.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
We'll just stick with...
Oh, this is not what I want to do.
We'll just stick with this one for now.
Maybe if I... Hold on.
Let's look at the skill list.
Ability.
Oh, not ability.
Style.
Nope, not... Oh, wait.
Sword.
Not Lucifer.
There we go.
While on the ground, press Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
Why?
Position swords around you and pierce your enemies repeatedly.
I feel like this would be a great weapon to use in the beginning.
Like, of the battle.
You pierce them.
So you get that extra, like, little...
You know, oomph in them and then you switch to another weapon.
Or something.
It's for set-ups, yeah.
While on the ground, Y.
Then Y.
And then Y.
While on the ground, press Y, Y.
Then Y.
And the enemy is suffering.
By launching them into a new realm of pain.
Y, Y, Y, Y.
Why?
They just sit there.
Ecstasy.
So you gotta, like, really aim it.
Wait.
Trigger the detonation of the blade's precision.
So you can...
So that's what you meant by...
Back and then Y.
The throw of the rose.
So first you get pierced and then you go into ecstasy.
Ecstasy.
Throw multiple swords and position them in the air in front of you.
Okay.
Looks like we can do some cool shit, but it's fussy.
I don't wanna give up on it just yet, but...
We'll see.
We'll see how I'm feeling first off.
You know.
Dante's improv dialogue was way better if he just kept saying Y, Y, Y.
Anything up here?
Oh, that's where I'm supposed to go.
Nothing up there?
Oh god.
I don't know.
Just remember Y, Y, Y, Y.
Oh my god, an alligator!
Oh shit, it's the grabby guy.
I
don't like you!
I'm sorry.
Go away, crocodile!
Did you guys see that outback?
Oh my god.
The new outback drink.
The crop tail.
Oh, that wasn't good.
Oh my god, you shoot too?
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, Dante!
There's a second one!
Oh, please, please, please!
There we go.
Oh, it's the shotgun.
Thank you.
I knew guns were good.
No, no, no, no, my money!
Wait!
I didn't start... I don't think I started attacking her, but...
Okay.
The children laugh.
Follow the little rope road.
Follow, follow, follow, follow, follow the little rope road.
Leads to nothing.
Nice secret.
Wait, if I just stand there, do you think something will drop?
Sad.
Sad!
Yay!
Tomatoes!
My healing substance.
Tomato, tomato.
Give me them grorbs, please.
Oh, that's a flag.
It's gonna say what's moving over there.
Can I chop these cars?
Dang.
So not this way.
Can I chop these?
Yes, I can.
I see a fragment!
Oh, big boy, big boy, big boy.
Big boy!
This is literally just the performance test!
There we go.
Here, let's get this guy over here.
You missed, Dante!
How could you miss?
How could you?
Yeah!
It does kinda sound like he's saying that though, no?
He's flailing everywhere.
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
I'm on fire.
Oh, it's the dogs!
Where did you come from?
Where did the dogs come from?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
There's another big boy?
Oh, no.
Shoot, I tried to dodge that.
Jump, jump, jump, jump.
Where are the dogs at?
You don't hear it?
You really don't?
Is the volume too low?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, don't even try, stupid dog.
What the dog doing?
Dog being crazy on me.
That's what the dog's doing.
OK, I think I broke everything that I could for...
Oh, please.
Do I have to be...
Dante, use your arms.
He's like, I can't lift my hands up too high in this outfit.
OK, D, T, now.
Oh, just kidding.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh my gosh!
New blue orb!
We got a full blorb.
Yeah, easy peasy.
Easy peasy.
Would you rather your cat ears or human...
Human... I'm not even a human!
Why does his outfit sound so wet when he's moving around?
Do you hear this?
Listen, I turned it up.
Why is it so wet?
Spongebob sounding ass over here.
It's so squishy.
Also, do not rub any ears.
Denied.
Denied on any ears.
The ears are not for rubbing.
Decorative purpose only.
Did I go over?
Bus is too big.
Oh, I thought that was a bench for a second.
I was like, why is there a bench in the middle of the road?
Wait, why are there so many doors?
All roads lead to Fire Emblem Hills.
So you don't want us to play favorites and you want us to rub both ears.
No!
Wait,
where are the doors?
Are they upstairs?
I'm trying to break an entry.
Wearing these ears was a mistake.
Stop distracting
me!
You're scratching.
Stop!
Secret.
What's this one?
This one might be a little hard for...oh wait, I'm going to try it though.
I'm going to try it.
Reach the goal!
Wait, how?
Wait, actually how?
What?
There's no stinking way.
Yeah, there's no time stop.
Crazy.
OK.
Let's go get ambushed or something.
What is flying above us?
What is this crazy shadow?
What is that?
It reminds me of those Halloween decorations.
You know what I'm talking about?
That's just like little witches flying about.
Wisp meet up.
Please!
Oh my god.
No.
There we go, finally.
Please!
Kill that thing!
Don't let it!
Come on Dante!
I need you to kill it like right now!
Where'd he go?
Please!
Oh, thank god.
These angel guys are so cool, but they are so annoying.
Please!
Come here!
Nevermind.
I changed my mind.
Come down here!
Oh, I messed up.
Yay!
I don't like this area.
It's so hard to see for some reason.
Get out of my way!
There are so many little areas to get trapped in here.
Oh nice.
Wait, I just got that.
Oh wait, come on.
Take him out.
Before he gets us...
What?
Sorry.
Oh, it's the big man!
I hate the most!
Sorry.
Oh my god, he scared the heck out of me.
This is times to DT.
Oh my god, please!
Kill!
Get him!
Stunlock him!
Stunlock him DT!
Stay away from me you freak!
I can't see anything.
I don't know where you are.
Stay away from me!
Where are you?
No, no, no.
Go get him.
Oh I got him.
That cat is barking about angels again.
Do I have to purchase that?
Oh, not this way.
Sorry.
Wait.
What's this door?
Wait, what's down here?
Hold on.
Are there two ways I go?
Can I go inside here?
Yes.
It's unlocked when you buy Swordmaster level 4.
That door is for Nero.
Well...
Well, it's also made for Dante.
It didn't say his name on it.
I don't think they'd let me go in if I...
couldn't, right?
Dante and Nero door.
Exactly.
I can get some special things in here.
There's another door.
I do remember this room.
But...
And look, we even got health.
I'm just...
It's right there.
The gorb.
And this is where we learned how to use the grabby grub.
Do I have to come back here as Nero?
Hold on.
I hate chairs.
Once is no way to...
Oh.
Okay.
Well, we just...
did a little bit of...
backtracking, I suppose.
It's fine.
Wait.
Can I destroy this?
Oh, no, I can't.
Okay.
Dante can use demon magic to create almost anything, yet the only thing he makes are unlimited ammo and roses to throw.
He's a simple guy.
He doesn't need anymore.
Right.
Chat, how did you get here?
I walked.
I took the door.
It's all about style.
Yeah.
I hope I don't have to fight those guys again.
Probably not, right?
Wait.
This is...
This is the door.
I bet Mint would like Nero's demon arm.
What's up?
Why are you so obsessed with the rubbing ears?
Uh-oh.
What are we about to fight?
I have two holy waters, so I don't feel like I should buy any more.
Obviously, I can't buy any more blorbs or porbs.
I have one...
Peek?
Here comes peek?
Really?
I'm excited.
Maybe I'll grab an M star.
And I have an L star.
And I have two double stars.
Best scenes?
Wait, really?
Let's go!
Is he going to sing?
Full power!
Why is the music so whimsical?
Oh!
Full power!
Oh it's so going!
Oh yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh, not some dogs.
Why dogs?
Why does it always have to be the dogs?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Let's get away from you.
Did he make these?
Is that why there are so many of them?
This guy is such a weenie.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Nice.
Oh, dang it.
I think I...
Demon.
I shouldn't have when I...
Wait, what's going on?
No!
Is he healing?
Oh you mother trucker.
Ouch!
Oh gosh.
I thought I could...
Ah!
Don't get away from me!
Ouch,
ouch, ouch.
How
do I...
How do I avoid this part?
Yeah, yeah.
Just attack?
Just hit him?
OK.
Wait.
Ah, shoot, shoot.
Oh, nice, nice.
What the hell?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
No, sorry, sorry.
I'm wondering if I want to heal or not.
I hate these!
These are the ones that go underneath, no?
You're still good?
Keep going?
Should be fine.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Wait.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
There we go.
Oh, more dogs.
That was close.
He's so close!
Nice!
What?
What's that?
Oh, he's writing his notes?
Please!
Not for the Sigma!
The research!
Oh, I just spilled my drink all over my...
Ah!
Motion capture on his YouTube channel.
Thank you brother.
Take a bow!
He actually did!
And the rest is silence.
Oh, that was mean.
I don't think I can...
I want to get something for my health.
I've always wondered why I like Agnes.
She's a nerdy little theater kid.
This stutters.
It's like looking at a mirror.
I still got them.
We're OK.
I was reading.
Thank you for the pig!
I'm getting a cough drop.
Real quick.
Real fast.
My money!
You really gave me a heart attack.
Me too!
Once I noticed it, I was like...
Oh, tomato!
I think that's what he meant.
I think this place is gonna blow.
Sorry, I forgot to turn it back down.
Holy cow!
Nice!
86%?
What did I miss?
B for Binto!
True.
One is not enough.
Keep going.
Blade mode.
It only
split once!
It didn't even...he missed all the other times.
Hey there.
Oh, trash.
Is Nero doing OK in there?
Yes, mama.
Got it.
Babe.
B for Brandon.
B for Babe.
9mm kills the body, but 45 ACP kills the soul.
What is that reference to?
Confront the savior.
Is there anything I should buy?
I wonder.
I can't even afford it.
Whoosh!
Round trip.
Press and hold Y.
All the rebellion moves.
I might even refund this.
Put on normal costume, Dante.
Long range moves help a lot here.
I see.
So should we up my guns?
Wait, so like Ebony and Ivory?
Kind of long range?
We talking?
Are we talking Charge Shot 3?
Or Pandora?
We talking?
I'm scared.
Pandora?
I got that maxed.
Pandora's spinning move is good enough as long as...I just have to make sure I aim.
Da, da, da, da.
Gunslinger is worth it.
Go with the...
Let's...I can't buy all of them.
Hold on, I'm gonna refund.
Sorry Lucifer.
Give me my money back.
Let's try that.
Well, I have to see what the mission is anyway, so you know.
OK, mission is...oh wait.
Mission menu.
Let's change our outfit.
Thank you for suggesting.
That was a good suggestion though for the Sparta outfit.
Thank you.
The outfit was too good.
I know people were kind of like hinting at like a silly moment would happen.
That outfit would be perfect for it.
But it exceeded my expectation.
How about death?
Yeah, do all the work for me, cutscene Dante.
Oh wow, went through his legs.
Damn, he opened his legs like he's used to it.
You ready to eat your words?
Oh, he's gone now.
You're too slow.
Wow, why doesn't my gun work like that?
Don't tell me I have to parkour here.
Yamato!
Katana used by Dante's brother.
It is the key to opening the hell gates, but also the key to their destruction.
Dark Slayer.
After obtaining Yamato, it can be used with the powerful Dark Slayer style.
Wait a second, I just spent all my money.
To select Dark Slayer style, press the button of the currently selected style again.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait, what?
It's not its own thing?
Hold on!
Yo, wait!
Wait!
Holy hell!
Oh my god.
What is this?
What?
Friendly fire!
I'm not at the beginning, am I?
Oh wait, that's where I just came from.
Oh, that's where I just came from!
Hello.
Oh, that's not what I'm supposed to do.
Where am I?
What do I do?
Oh shoot.
What are you doing out here?
I'm on your arm now, mister.
I'm running.
Hit
the blue thingies?
OK, OK.
I gotta get on his other arm, no?
I'm trapped here.
Break it more?
Oh, OK.
Fully break it.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, OK.
I thought I had gotten it.
Thank you guys.
OK.
Oh,
did I get hit mid?
No way.
Anything up here?
Oh.
Oh gosh!
Uh-oh.
Dang it, I missed my chance.
He just slammed his arm down.
Can I like bait him into... Oh my god.
Friendly fire, friendly fire!
Go, go, go!
Wait, no, not you.
Turn around, turn around.
No, not you.
Turn around.
Oh gosh!
Oh gosh, I'm gonna die here.
Oh wait, OK.
No, no.
Oh, wait.
This is good.
That's good.
Yeah, that's good.
DT!
Yeah, you're right.
I should DT.
Oh wait, I'm on the same arm as before.
And charge!
Oh, I did it.
Somehow.
Uh-oh.
Holy moly.
Again, again!
Oh, I'm still DT'ed.
Oh shoot.
You know what?
Maybe that's OK.
Can you slam your other arm?
I don't want this one.
Other arm.
Holy... Wow, that's a critical crotch.
Crotchity, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch.
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
Oh my god, ouch.
Wait, I'm scared.
Wait, what am I supposed to do here?
Hit the cannon.
Cannon?
Fire the cannon?
Use the thing.
Cannon?
This thing.
Oh!
Chill out!
Wait, what else am I supposed to hit now?
Oh, there's these guys here.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice.
What else am I supposed to get?
Hit it more?
There we go,
there we go.
I think more, even more, even more.
Do I have to do that all over again?
On the leg.
More?
How do I get to his leg?
Legs and back.
OK.
I don't think I can reach from here.
Wait, can I?
Wait, I'm getting further away.
I don't think I'm doing this correctly.
There we go.
Climb!
Climb on!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, where am I?
Pistols have better range?
Probably, no?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I'm down though, I'm down.
Please, please, leave me alone.
Please, there's too much to worry about here.
Please, please.
Friendly fire!
Friendly fire, please.
There we go.
Oh shoot.
Oh, oh.
Fire,
friendly fire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, no, no, no.
Friendly fire, friendly fire, friendly fire.
Friendly fire, friendly fire.
I don't, I don't, I'm confused, you guys.
I'm so confused.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh gosh, I'm gonna die here.
I'm really confused about this part.
Oh!
Like how am I supposed to... I'm confused.
I'm just gonna keep moving around.
The cannon?
Again?
Oh god, where was it?
You can use Yamato by pressing the style button twice.
Like that button?
Or that button?
Oh, I'm Dark Slayer now.
Wait, but what does Yamato do?
Now use B.
Good stuff.
Oh nice, that actually was so good.
That was actually so good.
Am I supposed to...
Get up on the Hydra's back!
I'm so confused.
Oh gosh.
I don't... Wait, this is the cannon.
Where's your back?
Where's your back, buddy?
It won't let me on him.
Oh gosh, where do I go?
Where's more?
More, more, more.
Oh god.
Hey, leave me alone.
I'm lost.
Wait, I can't even see him now.
I can't move the camera.
Where'd he go?
Okay, I'm back where I started.
Now the legs.
Okay, we gotta get...
Shotty got low, low, low, low, low, low.
Where though?
How do I get downstairs?
Hold B.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Okay, I got that one.
Hold B?
I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding.
No, please.
I don't care about you.
Please.
Okay,
back to the cannon.
Back to the cannon.
Somewhere.
Maybe behind me.
Okay, I gotta get down, down there.
Wow, wow.
Okay,
get on the savior's back.
Okay, that should be all of them but the chest, right?
That doesn't seem...
That doesn't seem good, that doesn't seem good, that doesn't seem good.
I
can't see anything right now.
There we go.
Do I go back to the...
No?
That's it.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
That was so...
That was so... Oh no.
Oh no.
Phase two.
Wait.
Can I... Wait.
Circle, circle.
Wait, how do I use this thing again?
Oh wait, I'm not on it.
Somehow...
Use the pistol?
Really?
Hold on, I'm just running around in here.
He's so scary.
You missed me slowpoke.
What if I just jump between two things?
Am I even hitting him?
Oh no, he broke it.
Oh no!
Where are you?
Where are you mister?
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
This garage...
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run Dante.
Wait, is he moving it?
No.
I don't think so.
Ok, it stays in one place.
That's enough.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to...
Oh shoot!
Wait, please don't.
Oh my god.
I need to use... I need to use trickster or something for some of these...
Damn attacks.
He sucks so much.
Like I need to stay so close to...
Oh thanks for the warp.
Oh dang it, I just...
Ok, run, run, run, run, run.
I think he is about to destroy that one too, no?
This is DMC2, right?
That was so stinking close.
Get like two hits in and I'm...
This is stupid.
This fight is so stupid.
This is a method.
Yeah, you're telling me.
You're telling me.
Go, go, go!
Go, go.
Health bar, go down tiny bit.
Tiny...
Ah!
I tried.
Sometimes you get stun locked in like the...
When you use gunslinger.
The style.
This is so stupid.
Please let me DT again, please.
Please let me DT again.
Is he regaining health?
I can't tell.
I feel like I'm getting nowhere.
She'll find it.
Wait, find what?
There's something?
Put me out of my misery.
It's just very slow.
Keep going, this way.
I'm gonna die though, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna lose health.
I wish I could go faster.
Is there a cannon or something?
Oh god.
Wait, run, run, run, run.
Oh shoot, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Stay there.
Here?
Oh,
I'm gonna die.
Restart?
I don't think so.
Hell no, I think I'd rather use items.
In fact, I'm gonna do this.
Hold on.
Can I holy water him?
Is he close enough?
Okay, I'm just gonna use the big boy.
Keep going left?
I don't think I can, can I?
Wait, what do you mean to... Oh no, he's too far?
Okay.
You can stinger input with... I don't... I tried using Yamato, I don't... Wait.
I don't know how to use it.
Wait.
Oh!
Okay, that was really good.
Like here?
Wait, stay there and fight.
What do you mean Mito?
I don't know.
I don't know this fight.
You guys can't be like Mito.
I'm just trying...
No,
I was on a melee platform.
I didn't know.
Maybe I should just restart.
I have no motivation.
Where is your motivation?
Wait.
I'm trying to stinger him.
I'm back.
Guys, I'm just getting my ass kicked.
For real.
I'm just getting my ass kicked.
I tried.
He just comboed me.
I did press B.
Is Dark Slayer not Yamato?
It is.
Yeah, so then I am...
I wasted my... I wasted my health.
I wasted my heal.
Oh well.
Wait, he's down!
Go Dante, go!
Please, do it!
Do it!
I don't
know what that was.
What?
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I for some reason thought that they would...
not go through... that they would be blocked by...
It worked?
Did that work?
Oh no!
I was too far!
Oh, we made some good damage there though.
OK, that's good.
Nice.
I at
least made some good damage there.
Oh...
Dante, you're shaking.
I don't even know where I'm going.
Stop jumping around.
I'm just trying not to die!
I'm just trying not to die here.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Guys, this is it.
Oh!
Please, come here.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here, come here.
Wait.
Oh, this is the platform.
Wait, is this
the platform?
I don't know anymore.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're so close.
Why won't he do his little thingy again with his face?
OK, we locked him.
We stun locked him again.
OK, let's go and do our big cut.
Big cut time!
Holy cow.
Oh god.
Oh!
OK, so once I knew you could melee him on there...
It wasn't as bad, but I was so... That was definitely a designed boss.
Nero!
Little baby.
Very gimmicky boss.
Oh, he's gonna be birthed.
A baby is born.
He's a healthy baby boy.
Wait, wait.
What about Kitty A?
Is she dead dead?
Yes, I will save her.
Let's clean up this mess.
Nero!
That only took 20 minutes?
Why did it feel like I was on that for like 3 hours?
It felt like I was there for like...
Forever.
That felt so long.
It's a boring fight.
Oh my gosh, it felt like...
T for Dante!
It's a confusing mission.
Thank you guys for trying to help.
I just...
What?
They're like...
You gotta get the blue things, but I don't know how to get the blue things.
Then you gotta do other things.
Thank you for the raid, Hunter.
I'm gonna get this done.
Good luck...Kid.
Frog for Rabbit, thank you so much for the buy.
Thank you!
Don't call me Kid.
Can I now power up Yamato?
There he is.
What can we get?
When did I suddenly get all...
I was like when did I suddenly get 18,000?
While Devil Trigger is active, the depletion of the DT gauge will be reduced.
Oh wait, that's Trigger Heart.
Maximum bet when Devil Trigger is active.
Press on the ground.
Y plus B.
Oh gosh, these are like gamer moves.
These are...
What?
You realize you're Nero again, yes?
Yeah, that's why I said I refunded everything.
So we gotta get all our stuff back.
I'm assuming?
Wait a second.
Oh no, nevermind.
Refunded only our...
Oh, I thought I would refund everything.
Oh, I guess that makes sense because Trigger Heart is still...
Ah, nice!
Okay, cool.
My birthday offering...
To my favorite gamer, ghost maid, cat girl, devil hunter...
Kamrinin, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Kamrinin.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Okay, let's see.
Well, that's nice that it...
I think because when we switched to Dante...
It gave us all of our orbs from Nero.
I just assumed that it was like refunding them.
But that's nice that it actually kept them.
Okay, cool.
And so...
Oh, snatch.
Yes!
XP share while Dante played his campaign.
Yeah, it's like that, right?
It refunds the other character's ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, should we get...
I will try to use this.
I will try.
While on the ground, press RB, back.
Then YB.
Is it like YB at the same time?
Or Y and then plus B?
One year!
Thank you!
Game was like, sorry, that boss sucked.
Here's your money back.
Same time, okay.
But it has to be while in Devil Trigger.
Both of these are when in Devil Trigger.
Okay.
Okay, this is our...
Our stinger.
But now we have the grabby grab, so honestly...
Who needs a stinger?
Can't use Yamato without DT, okay.
Let me grab this one too.
Can't wait for the next year for me to fly.
Sure, steer!
Thank you!
Y and Y, Y.
You know what, maybe... We have so much now.
Why don't I just get a bunch of stuff?
Y.
Okay, let's get this too.
Caliber is fun.
Back to forward is like what will probably mess me up though.
I feel that it doesn't hurt to have stuff.
Because if I accidentally do the combo then...
We're winning.
Because I have it.
Okay, I was just making sure.
I have all the stuff for Blue Rose.
I have the stuff for Devil Bringer.
I'll try it.
Okay.
That is not incorrect.
The next missions will throw a lot at you.
Be prepared.
Oh golly.
What, we have what?
Three missions?
Wait, no.
What one is this?
Actually, where are we?
I'm gonna buy more stars since I used one here.
And I used a big one.
Buy that back.
I guess I could have used devil stars during that last thing too.
But it all worked out.
In the end, it worked out.
Buy two?
Really?
Two of the vital stars?
Why not?
We got robes to spare.
Oh yeah, we have two missions.
Surmount the stairs of tribulation.
That doesn't sound good.
That?
That's a boss rush.
Ogre this level!
Oh, Capcom boss rush.
No!
No, wait!
I've been suffering with bad mental recently.
No, Phil!
A lie!
The stairway to heaven or hell.
Thanks for the super chat by the way.
Thank you so much.
I hope you feel better.
Know that we control it and all will be well.
If it is progress that you desire, moving your other self past the stairs is required.
And now your fate we decide.
Strike us or your progress will be denied!
No kidding, huh?
Wait, is this all luck?
No way.
Thank you!
Yippee!
Does it matter when I hit it?
The numbers will go in a set pattern and whatever is on top when you hit is the number you get.
Yellow seems good.
Wait, ok, it's so fast.
Did I get it?
Was I too slow?
I was too slow.
Well, that's not bad.
Yippee!
You have to use B.
Really?
Oh wait, I was... I'm an idiot.
I'm so stupid.
Oh, I'm dumb.
I'm really stupid.
Oh, I'm really dumb.
Why?
Why was it... I was literally one track mind.
It's coming so fast.
We're just... We're farming.
Obviously.
Ok, yellow.
One, two, three.
Alright, three.
Four?
Oh, I didn't count the purple.
Yippee!
Ok,
one.
Ok, ok, I'm paying attention.
I'm paying attention.
It's after five.
Five of...
Ok.
Well, white is nothing.
Blue is orbs.
Purple is the goal.
Red is enemies.
Yellow will also take you to the goal.
Come on!
Let me have your sword!
Or your shield, please!
They're all such a little hive mind.
Why?
Oh my gosh, we haven't heard this song in a bit.
Come on!
Oh, please, let me leave.
Ok, hold on.
Am I doing it?
I did it!
Oh, shoot.
I'm such an idiot.
I should've...
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Stop.
Oh my god, please.
Mister, mister, mister, mister.
I can't see anything.
Please be gone.
I don't remember how to take your shield.
Can I at least kill one of you, please?
Oh, thank you.
Ask and you shall receive.
Receive.
Wait, I can now grab you.
And you too!
Suplex!
You can grab them from the back.
Thank you.
Smoking.
Did we really get to smoking?
Nice finish.
A little grove over there.
And a little...
War?
Wait, so yellow is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
What's the difference between getting purple and getting yellow?
Anything?
What's the difference between purple and... Is it the same?
Nothing.
Oh, no diff.
Yellow an instant cheat to the finish.
Purple the finish.
I see.
So, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
We'll do 5 or 6.
I guess it doesn't matter.
Oh, it's so fast now.
You're not supposed to cheat the dice so it gives better odds.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
I'm trying to remember how to fight him.
How do I jump?
Maybe I'm too slow with it.
Ah, come on!
I'll jump.
I jumped!
Seriously?
He's parrying.
What a stinker.
Please don't.
You didn't think you could defeat a Capcom game without a boss rush?
It's actually my least favorite mechanic ever.
It's my least favorite thing ever.
I'm not gonna lie.
Doing boss rushes is just so... I don't know.
I get why some people would like it, but...
It's so...
Yeah, it really just does feel like filler.
I don't wanna jump.
I'll get health back if anything.
Oh, come on!
The guy changed his direction.
I feel like I'm gonna die here.
It's to show how much you've grown.
I hate it.
I already went through the trials.
I love boss rushes, but I think they should be mostly optional.
Yeah, I can agree with that.
I hate growth.
Yeah!
I haven't grown since elementary school!
I think I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
Why aren't you grabbing him?
Oh, I'm not gonna lie.
I forgot that I had that option.
I'm gonna die.
This sucks.
No way.
Wait, no, I'm trying to...
Get his ass!
Literally!
Oh, ouch, ouch.
He's so close.
You bitch.
I didn't get the finish clap.
One down out of how many?
When you say you haven't grown since elementary school, do you mean mentally or physically?
Both, probably.
Wow, they're like, you need to grow orbs.
We know it.
How fast is this thing gonna get, anyway?
I wish I could cheat this section.
How many more are there?
Boss rushes are only fun when you're super OP and get to vent your frustration.
OK, after one.
Ah.
And this is the third time I've had to fight this guy, even.
Like, don't even.
Don't make me fight him again!
Actually, wait, also the other guy.
It's the third of every boss.
You're right!
Yeah, because we had to... Oh my gosh, dude.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Is he gonna do it?
Too far away.
I have to save some DT just in case I get caught.
Where is he?
Where'd they go?
Oh.
Where are they?
No!
That was close.
Stop spinning!
Oh, no, no, no!
That was close.
Get away from me, sexy ladies.
I'm not in the mood.
I have a headache.
Nero only cares about one woman.
He's so... He's so dedicated.
Oh
my god, that's so lame.
I was already DT'd.
And then I...
Again!
Please let me live.
No, please, please, no.
Get me again.
Oh my gosh.
I'm scared.
I feel like I'm gonna die again.
Get up on the hydra's back.
If they don't give me like a place to...
Be able to buy more stuff, I'm gonna be so...
I'm gonna be so... It's so over for me.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, it's gonna be so over for me.
I lose all motivation in these kinds of fights.
Where it's like just...
Just redoing stuff.
It's just not fun for me.
I've already done this fight so many times.
If I'm playing the game again, like that's one thing.
This is so lame.
This is so stinking lame.
Sorry to complain all the time.
I just hate this.
I hate this!
Please, come here.
Where did you come from?
Oh, come on.
No, please.
This gets done now.
I tried to dodge.
There's no... I don't know.
I don't know.
This is actually so unfair.
What the... Why are you on the ground?
Are you waiting for me?
Is this an imitation, maybe?
I'll take the rorps, though.
I don't even understand logically why we're fighting them again.
Did we not close the portal and kill them and do all that good stuff?
This doesn't even make any sense.
What's happening?
Why couldn't I attack for a second?
I tried to grab him.
He was one of the bosses I didn't really have an issue with so much.
Last time even, so now I'm like...
Feeling a little nervous.
The demons are using the power of lack of time and budget to come back.
It's so true.
1, 2, 3, 4...
OK, after 1.
I went on 1.
Taking my anger out on these guys a little bit.
Come here.
Taking my anger out on you!
Just a little bit!
Actually, this is kind of good to regain, I guess...
DT.
Hey,
stop it.
Stop doing that.
This pug.
There we go.
Let's see if we...
Will we get health if I go to the blue?
After 4.
Yes?
Oh, sometimes.
OK, let's try that then.
A little bit pause...
Oh yeah, that's right!
I remember that...
I remember there's some of it falling from the sky.
OK, OK, OK.
Now we just need to do 1.
Which is after...
No, wait.
Wait, I keep missing it.
5, after 5.
Doing the big combo.
Here we go!
Oh, goodness.
Thank you, lady.
Oh my goodness.
I don't remember how to dodge very well as Nero.
Just jump?
Oh, that's what I'm doing.
Oh, what am I doing?
Oh, she's really spitting them out this time.
Wait, grab?
Ouch.
The trick
with her is just staying up in the air.
Oh, stop it, stop it!
Please let me hit you.
OK.
Holy...
Oh, shoot.
I can't tell you what I can't do.
OK.
That's what she does.
Please, let me hit you.
Oh, please.
There we go.
I thought that would be enough.
Please.
So close.
So close!
Alright.
She's like the easiest out of everybody, I think.
She's super duper easy.
Oh, there we go.
Nero?
Oh, the sun is shining!
How many more bosses are there?
Do I have to also go with the Angus Beef?
Do I have to fight him again too?
Aggression with Nero is rewarded a lot because when you stun the bosses you can grab them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
One last guy before the final boss.
Wait, final?
Like, final of the game or final of this mission?
Final of the game!
1, 2, 3...
Well, actually I don't think I need it.
Let's go with gold then.
Hold on.
1, 2, 3...
5!
Or 6.
Ok, after 3.
Oh, it's a heart!
How cute.
It really is him again!
Wait, hold on!
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, how do I...
At least when I fought him as Dante it was like in a separate room, you know?
So, it felt a little different.
It felt...
Stop stunlocking me please.
I've never seen that!
That's crazy!
That was so awesome!
Oh.
Yeah,
stupid.
Oh, damn!
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I couldn't move.
I was stunlocked.
No!
I'm just sitting here.
Wait, ah!
I should've... I should've grabbed him!
I'm such an idiot!
I didn't think about it.
I should've grabbed him!
Oh, oh, ow!
You son of a gun!
You!
I hate you!
Dummy.
Stupid, stupid, stupid head.
Stupid, stupid, stupid head!
I'll just eat the damage.
Eat the damage!
Oh, oh, wait.
I do want to get out of this way, though.
Ah, bees, please!
Wait, grab him!
Just a little bit more.
Just a little bit more!
Don't get stunlocked, Nero.
Oh, god.
I don't want him to grab me.
Oh my god, he's so close.
Oh, he's dead.
I thought he had one HP and a dream.
OK!
No dream for this guy.
Wait, can I get more health?
Can I roll the dice one more time?
Can I get...
Here we go!
Oh, the mission's done.
Yay!
My gambling addiction.
I was pretty good at it, though.
The casinos hate her.
Yeah, Dante, I had to clean up your mess.
Again!
Well, he had to clean up mine.
I'm going through it.
What are you talking about?
You're going...
Triple A!
Wowie, guys.
Are we really on the last mission?
We made it through the boss rush!
Yay for us, everybody.
Yay for us.
I have to use the little ghosties room real quick.
Wow, maybe... Well, I don't want to jinx myself.
I was going to say, maybe we'll finish the stream way sooner than I expected, but...
I don't want to jinx myself.
What if it takes me five hours to find the final boss?
What if?
I think compared to DMC3 boss rush, this one wasn't as bad.
I feel like we... I don't know.
I feel like we...
Maybe.
I think the sexy lady should...
Sorry, I just pulled out my headphones.
I think she's just way too easy.
Koharu!
I guess she gave me luck.
DMC3 is harder in general.
Once you got past the frog, it was easy.
I don't know why the frog gave me such issues.
I'm still getting used to Nero, maybe, I guess.
It's the changing styles that throws you...
Yeah, yeah, the changing styles that throws you off in this one.
Yeah, because as soon as you're used to Dante, they're like, Hey, wasn't that fun?
Here's Nero for three missions.
As a heads up, you can counter the boss's charging attack with a grab.
I will try to remember that, Mr. Orange.
Thank you!
Is there any other tips I should know?
Is this boss really hard?
Is he like crazy, crazy difficult?
No, no, no, you got this.
You fought this boss before.
Lamest final boss ever.
Not long if you live.
I'm gonna buy some big stars.
Oh, that's a devil star.
I'm gonna buy a devil star.
We'll buy that.
We'll buy...
Oh, it's so expensive.
We can buy an M-star.
Yeah, the M-stars give us a lot of health.
Just keep grabbing.
JKG, just keep grabbing.
Remember you can bust her.
I hardly even know her.
Does holy water work against this guy?
Because we got two.
I got two holy waters.
Save the rorps for DMC5.
Would they transfer over?
That would be insane.
Cheese water.
If you do it with the shield down...
Oh, that's right.
I was like, when did we fight the old man?
Yes!
Yes, I do remember fighting him.
Yeah, I had to keep grabbing.
If you win, you won't lose.
True, true, true.
I've seen people struggle with this boss.
Okay, okay, okay.
He can block holy water.
That's cheating, Sanctus.
Yeah, we punched him in the face.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
DT grabbed to beat him.
Okay.
So I should maybe buy another double star.
Double star, double star.
And we got two S stars.
I think we might be good.
I'm gonna buy an L star.
J, just in case.
J-I-C.
I have no small stars.
I have four...
I think we're gonna be good.
W star.
Save the rorps for 5.
Wait, actually, I'm confused.
Is this... I can't tell if you guys are pulling my leg.
They don't transfer.
Oh, you guys!
Next you're gonna say gullibles written on the ceiling.
W star, W star, W...
I guess we'll just buy more double stars, maybe.
Just keep double star, just keep double star.
And health star.
Oh, I can't... Oh, health star.
Health star.
Health...
I have three of them.
Three.
Okay, before we go though, I'm gonna use the little ghost's room, so...
I'll let you listen.
And now...
We'll be back.
Wait, I forgot to take my throat medicine.
It's so powdery.
We were premature.
Itadakimasu!
Donkey, donkey.
I forgot to get my...
I forgot to get my cup so I can get some more tea.
Tadaima!
Okaeri.
Tadaima.
You can't tell me tadaima.
Okaeri, I tell you okaeri.
I tell you.
Are we ready for it?
You guys, I feel like I got a little stinkus prematurely for that boss rush.
I think I was thinking of how much I suffered in three.
How much it angered me to my soul, which is all I am.
But, I got prematurely upset.
It wasn't even that bad.
Biggest stinkus.
Sorry, understandable.
Little stinkus, butaro stream.
No, he's biggest stinkus.
Okay.
Destroy the evil stinkus!
Let's go.
DMC3 was the training arc.
Truly.
But to be fair, I did just fight them as Dante.
Kirie!
Oh, golly!
How does anyone see this and not think it's demonic?
She's like, he's protecting me.
I like that.
Damn her hips!
She got that hourglass figure.
Google it.
Sorry, I was too distracted by her hips.
Word of God, it's Dante.
Oh my god!
Wait, hold on.
Sorry.
Thank you, biggest!
Yeah, I'm looking forward to DMC5.
Sorry, I wanted to turn it down.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Wait!
Ouch!
Okay, okay, hold on.
Oh, don't parry me.
Don't do that.
Oh,
he's down.
Oh my gosh.
I need to stop walking on while I'm like that.
I need to stop doing what I'm doing.
Oh my goodness.
I didn't realize what he was doing.
Where are you?
I don't remember this fight very much.
You know what?
What am I doing?
Ouch!
Stop, please.
Please.
Ouch!
Please, stop it.
Oh, please.
Please, grandpa.
Oh my god, I run into it every time.
I literally run into it every time.
Oh my god.
I suck.
Please!
I'm trying!
I'm grabbing!
Wait.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm so freaking bad at this.
I'm so bad at this.
Sorry.
God!
I'm literally... I am...
Oh, OK.
Wait.
I don't...
I wasted my last one.
That was unfortunate.
But this one.
I will not waste.
Yeah, I know I need to stun him first.
That's what I've been trying to do.
I'm not just running around for nothing.
Oh, he's gotta get his little...
What if I... Also, holy water.
And then what if I... Devil storm.
OK, and then... Oh, and then... Ah!
Grab him.
There we go.
Item maxing?
Yeah, absolutely.
What is this?
Well, I didn't know...
OK.
That's enough.
Yes.
What?
I should have just... I should have just busted it.
It's fine.
It's OK.
He doesn't deserve.
He doesn't deserve it.
You missed the jackpot.
It's OK.
I'm gonna grab you.
I'm gonna grab you away from there.
Ah!
I really am!
Yeah!
Go Nero, go!
Important thing is you won.
I really just...
Cheese is not the right word, but I paid to win for that fight.
Use all that you've learned in the game.
All that I've learned is to collect robes.
Yeah!
We saved that girl!
Kyrie, wake up.
Only true love's kiss will wake her up.
My girlfriend mom?
What are you
doing Dante?
Also sister.
Girlfriend sister.
Nero gets the maiden.
He is no longer a maiden then.
I'm not gonna lie, this would be a sick monument to keep in town though.
Thanks for sending me money, Damald.
Grandpa!
Wait, actually...
Go finish it.
Wait, what am I gonna do?
She's like, I'll think about it.
Guys, it's fine.
Don't give it any attention.
I can't tell if it's serious or not.
That was so abrupt.
I can't move.
Hello?
Wait, actually...
How am I supposed to...
I'm supposed to do that, right?
OK, I guess I gotta time it well.
What if I...and...
Oh, I didn't time it again.
And...
You
know what?
Maybe the super chatter is right.
He's so weak.
This is what I know some of you wish you could do to your Oshiers.
High
five.
High touch.
Nero going full wrestler with the claw.
I'm so cool.
Nailed it.
Ultimate head pat.
That's the lobotomy head pat.
What if you die there?
What happens?
Strong, great.
Wait.
You forgot this.
He's giving it back to us.
Our brother, who is dead?
So melodramatic.
Dante.
What's he doing?
I'm taller than him.
No.
Uncle Dante.
Is this the end?
Maybe.
Uncle?
I don't...well...he's not...I don't know if he's papa.
I just...you know, like how you call like a...
Yeah.
For now.
Kyrie.
She's accepting him.
He kept it.
Yeah.
Her necklace.
The BGM is so sweet.
Oh,
they're watching the show, eh?
Little perv.
Oh wait.
Thanks.
Don't wipe your mouth, you freak.
Oh, are you okay?
Oh my god.
I wish I could double trigger.
Wait, is this the thing where I have to defeat them?
Look at her just standing there.
They're totally just leaving her alone.
Oh wait, not you over there.
Protect her.
They're not going after her.
They don't care about her.
Maybe they do.
Wait, what are you doing looking at my girl for?
Oh wait.
Hey, you're getting awfully close to my girl.
Stay away from her.
Wait, I'm trying to...there we go.
Watch out, KDA.
Maybe move away a little bit.
Oh my god.
Wait, KDA.
KDA.
I think I'm stupid.
Wait.
Wait, I'm trying to...
KDA.
It happened off screen, so I totally protected her.
They were like, just roll the credits.
Wait, do I not get the kiss?
Can I redo it?
Give me another chance, KDA.
KDA, give me another...
I don't know why I didn't grab him.
Sorry, I was back in Dante mode.
Doomed romance.
Wait a second, it's not doomed.
See, I totally finished.
The time has come and so have I.
Bad end where?
Where?
Walk over to her.
Why are you staring at her from so far away, you freak?
Why are you being such a creep?
Nero, I can't...can I move?
Why are we just standing there?
Social distance.
Oh, a reflection.
Us in the pool.
This is so NGS2.
Feels like when Raiden is back with Rose.
Is she pregnant?
You did just let her get hit by a demon.
She's probably a bit mad at you.
No!
This is so beautiful.
Well done, Minto.
Thank you!
Right stick should mute.
Oh, you're right.
I can move it just a little tiny bit.
Thank you.
Earthquake!
Get down!
Trigger for zoom.
Oh, the jiggle physics.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't actually mean to do it that time.
That schnoz.
Oh, they are waffling.
He's so shy!
She likes his demon hand.
Hand holding.
Villain, thank you for the ping!
Add the spoof.
I don't know what the achievement I got though.
Probably just beating the...
The music is so pretty!
Yay!
Love your playthrough.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, no secret cutscene.
Sorry, sorry.
Wanna watch the secret ending on YouTube?
Yeah, I do!
Guess you are some casual gamer.
RachelGaming!
Thank you guys for the superchats.
Thank you.
Congrats on saving girlfriend, mommy, sister.
You conquered four DMC games.
I'm proud of you.
Thank you!
This game was so silly.
This game is definitely my favorite out of the four so far.
Everybody says five is even better so I'm excited to play it.
Logan, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you.
Next game is Peak.
Wow, I thought it was going to be 6-7 hours.
It's only 3 hours.
I cheesed the final boss.
I cheesed it.
You did not cheese.
I didn't?
I should have busted at the end though.
Gallery, Son of Sparta, Bloody Palace, Game Clear Bonus, History of DMC?
That's so exciting.
Hold on.
Give me the gallery.
The day, Dante.
The proprietor of Devil May Cry received a request from the beautiful Trish was truly a red-letter day.
For it was the day that he was asked to travel to Mallet Island and combat the demon emperor Mundus.
Just as his father, the legendary Dark Knight Sparta did ages before, Dante was tasked with stealing away Mundus.
Mundus responded to this challenge like any evil puppet master.
He sent his subordinates to exterminate Dante's family.
Empowered with demonic abilities thanks to the blood of Sparta coursing through his veins, Dante set off to perform the emperor's last rites.
After eliminating the demon sent to end his existence, Dante's journey took him to the immense castle said to hold the slumbering Mundus.
Wow, they're just really going through all of Devil May Cry.
The first one.
It was there that he met a demon named Nihiloangelo, the transformed soul of his departed brother Virgil.
Armed with the power inherited from his father and filled with regret over his brother's fate, Dante faced off in a final battle against Mundus.
Why?
Dante, a renowned devil hunter and born to a human mother in legendary Dark Knight Sparta.
Dante is the proprietor of Devil May Cry, a shop specializing in the elimination of demon kind.
There are some who say Dante, with his two pistols in his hand and a sword slung across his back, has even surpassed his father's power.
Trish, the mysterious beauty.
Trish was responsible for requesting Dante steal away the demon emperor Mundus.
Closely resembling Dante's departed mother, Trish is actually a demon crafted in that form by Mundus himself.
However, in the face of Dante's love, her human heart awoke, and now she works along with the devil hunter as his partner.
Nihiloangelo, the demonic knight who battled Dante on three occasions, surprisingly avoided his dirty tricks and improvised methods for which denizens of the underworld are so often known for.
At the root of Nihiloangelo's chivalry lies his origins, for within the demon's body rests the soul of Virgil and...
Mucho texto.
And skip.
Okay, anyway.
I thought it was gonna be not a history of the games.
I thought it was gonna be like a...
Like a...
Like a, oh this is how DMC got started.
You know.
This is so good.
Wait, can I move the camera?
Oh, there we go.
This side is so hot.
Oh my god.
Big ol' Angus beef.
Hold on.
Oh wow, it looks like I have four arms.
Wait, how does the song go?
Hold on.
What's the song called?
Out of Darkness?
Devil May Cry.
A voice calling you, calling you out of darkness.
Hear the devil's cry of sin.
Oh, always turn your back on him.
With the wind you go.
Still I dream of your spirit leading you back home.
I will give my gifts to you.
Grow your garden, wash it blue.
Is there no audio?
Character images.
Characters.
Wait, that's it.
I can't even zoom in.
I can't do anything.
Oh sorry, I'm in the way.
Wait, I'm right next to...
I'm in the game!
Check out the virtual cutscene if you can.
It's cool.
Prototype Nero.
EX color Nero.
I like the blue.
Nero in DT.
Look at his eyeballs.
Red Queen, Blue Rose, QDA.
Wait, I gotta be taller than that.
My sister wife?
Credo!
Credit card!
I don't think...I wouldn't have remembered his name if it wasn't written.
He's so close to me.
I think Angus might be my...I can't even say his name right.
Angus might be my favorite character.
How tall is Dante canonically?
Angus beef, Angus beef.
I love the face mask.
This is so lame.
Taller than you.
Oh my god the rose!
The rose in his mouth.
6'3"?
6'4"?
I think he's pretty tall.
What?
Wait, so then I would be like...
No way!
Does this look right?
Oh my god!
In the end we are all satisfied.
Yes, I take your hand.
This...no, I have to be taller.
This doesn't seem right.
This seems messed up.
The teeth!
Wow, wait that's insane.
This looks so cool.
Sorry, I'll get out of the way now.
Wow, Devil Trigger Sparta.
Wait, so if I'm in this outfit and I Devil Trigger, that's what it looks like?
What?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Dante small.
Dante in DT.
Sorry, I have no words.
I can't say it.
If I speak, I am in trouble.
Lady.
I wish we saw more lady.
I know you can play as lady in Trish, no?
God.
Trish!
Gloria!
She's not wearing panties.
You don't see them.
Unless it's like the most high-waisted...
Like they have to go up to here.
You can what?
They are so cute.
Bianco Angelo.
It's a sticker?
Look up the cutscenes.
She wears a sticker.
Nice.
Frost, Assault, Blitz.
Wait, where is this guy?
The bane of my existence.
Burial.
Echidna.
So sexy.
Wait, we didn't get all the boss images.
That's weird.
I thought we would see more Blitzes.
Thank goodness we didn't.
Thank...
I love this.
Mega Scarecrow.
Gosh, they look so cool.
I love the Scarecrow designs.
They are so, so cool.
Actually, all the enemies in this game look really awesome.
All the enemies are just very cool.
On higher difficulty.
Glorious.
Oh, these are the ones that go under, no?
No, that's the Cutlass.
Glorious.
Oh, those are the ones that are flying around and you have to shoot them.
You can play as Lady and Trish.
I can't even see it.
They did Basilisk so dirty.
Oh wait, are those his eyes?
I can't tell.
Oh, I was like, what the hell is that?
Yes.
It looks so awesome when he infects the Scarecrow.
You don't really get a good look at it.
Oh my gosh, it kind of reminds me of...
What's it called?
If you go back to the bonus art gallery you'll find nice art of all the ladies.
What?
Did I miss it?
It looks like Davy Jones from Pirates of the Caribbean.
You can inspect the model.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm just going through the...
I just want to see the...
models.
Faust.
Alto Angelo.
Fault.
Oh, that's all it showed me.
No Blitz?
Oh, maybe I can turn them if I inspect them, let's see.
Oh, I can just zoom.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
He's so cool.
Ok, so wait, where am I going to see all the lovely ladies?
To gallery?
Bonus?
I don't think I got another bonus though.
Yeah, I only have one out of one.
I only have one out of one.
Congrats on beating DMC4.
Folks want some kind of DMC slice of life?
There's a 2007 DMC anime where Dante eats ice cream.
And where lady met Trish.
Look at those hips swaying.
Yeah, I don't think I have it unlocked.
Maybe I have to...
Is that the main menu?
Alrighty!
Thank you!
Congrats on beating the game.
Good job Mito!
Also Nekomimi.
Thank you!
Capcom is successful because it takes feedback from its players.
So the issues you have definitely got back to the dev teams for five.
Really?
So they're changing the game as we speak?
That's so cute!
That's so cute that it updated.
Store?
My game froze?
My game froze.
It's opening Steam store?
Oh, but it didn't.
My game just froze.
Wait, you can actually buy... Like Steam store.
Like you can... What do you buy?
It's opening Steam somewhere.
It's not.
DLC?
Wait, like better weapons?
What do you get?
There are other intro cutscenes if you want to check out the other characters.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, if my game didn't freeze.
No way!
You can buy...
You can spend real money to buy...
No way!
Then I have to close out the game.
And the game won't close.
You can buy...
No way!
DLC!
Oh my gosh, wait, how much is it?
I can... Wait, what is this?
View page.
Ok, hold on.
Downloadable content.
Buy S Nero Dante Virgil.
I can buy Smol Dante.
I can buy Lady in Trish Costumes.
Proud Souls!
20,000 Proud Souls!
And... Wait, sorry, sorry, I said 20,000.
200,000 Proud Souls!
200,000!
And then you can buy 300,000 Red Orbs!
I thought I... Does anyone actually buy these?
Wait, do they have reviews?
Positive.
What are the reviews?
The first one is just... Motivated.
Recommended.
Recommended, thank you.
Now I'm going to buy tons of Blue Orbs.
One person said not recommended.
It won't let me buy the Red Orbs.
I don't have the DLC in my library, but it keeps saying I already have it in my library.
Recommended.
Can I buy 300,000 Orbs again?
Recommended, 10 out of 10.
Recommended, yes.
Recommended, make the game less grindy-ey DLC.
This is too much.
Play the game!
What do you mean?
I'm opening it back up.
We'll watch the other cutscenes.
I do want to see how Lady and Trish...
play, because I think that's really exciting.
There it goes.
That's too much.
Oh no, we lost her...
We lost her home screen.
Let us know if you watch the DMC Madhouse anime.
It's connected to DMC5.
I'm going to watch all the anime after I finish the game.
Devil May Cry.
OK, let's see.
Devil Hunter 1.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Virgil looks so cool.
Lady and Trish.
I'm just going to go on human mode.
The girls are so hot.
They really are.
I want pizza.
I'm going to be honest.
Trish reminds... Lady I'm in love with.
Lady is absolutely my type.
She's so hot.
Trish...
Trish looks like the female version of Ocelot.
Like the official version.
We never got to see her do that.
This is so fun.
Thanks can't unsee.
See you there.
Hot stuff.
Oh my god, the jiggle physics are great.
They're just subtle enough that it makes me excited.
Trish looks better in 5.
I don't know.
Lady is really hard for me to beat.
She's entirely my type.
Are they?
That was too close.
Now, will I replay the game as the other characters?
If I do any of them, I might do Virgil.
Because that's the most interesting for me.
Because I'm like, why are you even here?
And it probably would be...
Like, the members.
I don't know.
Oh no, they took all the pizza!
God, I want pizza.
It's early enough, I can still get pizza.
Virgil is so OP.
You try Virgil, he's busted.
I mean...
I'm so close!
Busted you say?
Gosh, they really know what the people want.
It's about as big as your head.
I'm bigger.
Oh, your character will move in the direction you press...
Wait, we're fighting.
We're fighting, Dante.
Oh, attack with your... OK.
OK.
I did it.
Jump.
OK, I did it.
Oh wait.
Jump.
Do it again.
OK, I did it.
How do I switch?
Oh, jump.
Oh wow.
OK.
Side roll.
Bayonet combo.
Why?
Oh, she's slow.
Nice.
Taunt.
What does she do when you taunt?
Oh god, wait.
Change gun.
Yeah, I did that.
Burst attack.
Help me to throw grenades.
Let's have at least three levels of Burst Gauge.
Ow,
I'm trying to taunt.
Stop it, Dante.
Oh, she's like tying her shoe.
That's so cute.
Oh, he blocks it.
That's crazy.
Oh, she doesn't do like a...
What's it called?
Attack?
I think her stinger is on the shotgun.
Oh, she does the same...
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Stop deflecting it.
Come on, Dante.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what about Trish though?
What about Trish though?
Right in the bongo.
You killed Dante.
Trish is in Dante's house.
I see, I see, I see.
Let's go try Virgil too.
I'm really curious what the opening cutscene is with him.
He looks so good.
Should we watch this?
I feel like we should, no?
It's totally different.
Why are you here?
To test Trish's new bloody power.
OK, I thought...I was like wait, is this just the opening video or the intro movie, but it's not.
Like you know from the main menu.
That's what I'm talking about.
This is before DMC3.
The Order of the Sword, huh?
Oh, they're building him!
They worship a demon as a god.
I can see his pores!
Virgil, your skin care!
He looks so young though.
He's like 16?
I don't want him to do that.
More close to 18.
I see, I see.
At most like 17.
I got it, I got it.
Impeccable impression, Niki.
Thank you, Brooks!
The Samurai.
Pay child support?
What are you talking about?
This guy is just a baby.
Oh, it's his cloak.
So cool.
Is this Assassin's Creed cosplay?
It looks...
It's just a closet cosplay.
It looks so...
Is that a kitty?
Oh, there's spoilers?
Wait, what?
I missed?
Wait.
Don't worry about it?
Don't reach out.
OK!
Okey-dokey.
What should we buy?
We can buy...
Oh my God!
Wait, he has everything already.
This is insane.
Wait!
This is awkward.
Oh, don't let him get too close.
Right.
He's just saying he's motivated.
By peepee?
He still says it.
Show me your motivation.
Wait, so is...
Dante actually the uncle?
I just said that because it's like...
Hey, uncle.
Why?
Oh, oops.
Oh, come on.
You're not supposed to actually do anything.
I did it, but...
Why am I so...
Stop it, Dante.
Did I get spoiled?
In Japan, everyone over 30 is an uncle.
That's what I was like.
That's why I said uncle.
I was just like, you know, you call an old guy an uncle.
No?
OK.
Please.
Upper slash.
Wait.
Like that?
Stop taunting me, you son of a bitch.
Stop!
Wait, what was it?
This one's so good.
He's stealing away my things.
Stop taunting me.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to...
There we go.
OK.
Stop it, Dante.
OK, we did it.
This is so cute watching them fight.
Change...Oh.
I didn't even try to.
He's got his own singer.
Wait, this is also familiar.
Wow, only he can deflect some of them.
He can't even deflect all of them.
That's crazy.
Wait, what other story?
Oh, what's this?
Oh, it's Beowulf.
Oh my gosh, I have to learn literally every...
Every weapon.
Oh my gosh, he's already down.
Oh yeah, DT.
Fine.
Virgil is cracked.
Goodness gracious, this guy.
It's crazy having every single weapon.
Like from the get-go.
He kept Beowulf since last time.
He just has his whole gameplay kit from DMC3 because it's not a canon game mode.
Nice.
Virgil's easy mode.
Secret ending, yeah.
Let's watch it.
Let me pick...Let me pull it up.
Let me pull it up.
Devil may cry for secret ending.
Everything that comes up is secret mission.
No, secret ending.
No ending...Wait.
Devil may cry for secret...OK.
The other one was like 7 and a half minutes long.
That's crazy.
OK, hold on.
Give me a second.
Let me pull it up for you guys.
Oh, oopsie.
Hold on.
Wait, I almost...OK, let me do this.
Wait, stop.
Stop!
Stop, please!
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I forgot to crop it.
Hold on.
Ah!
I'm all over the place.
Wait, let me crop it.
OK, so look at my recommended.
Look at my recommended.
OK, OK, OK.
Exposed!
OK, this is the secret ending.
Given to us by Raiken Studio.
Thank you!
OK, Matarikon.
I would never watch Matarikon!
I would never!
OK, OK.
We good?
Is this the right one?
Let me know if it is or not.
It is?
OK, why...this quality.
Oh, this is the highest quality.
360p baby.
Let's go.
What is he reading?
Is that Lady in the magazine?
Really?
This video is from 16 years ago.
What should we do?
It's so loud!
I can't hear you Dante speak up!
Are you ready?
Let's rock!
Come on!
Come on babes!
Oh sorry, I was like what the hell?
Is this the guy's fucking game?
I was like wait there is more.
Is this guy's outro?
I was like why does it sound like Legend of Zelda?
I was like oh wow, what's gonna happen next?
Here, I'll show you guys my actual...here you go.
You can see my...you can see my...here we go.
There's me.
Hold on, hold on.
Then, there's Metal Gear.
And then Toho.
There, I'm exposing myself.
Someone was like is that Hina?
Yeah, that's Hina.
There, because I made the mistake earlier.
And then there's also Hime Hina.
To not look at that DMC one.
This is so fun!
No way, Metal Gear.
Zelda's Lullaby was so abrupt.
I can't believe Dante shot Link from Legend of Zelda.
It was like he got...he shot the screen and then it was like...
It was like Link was dying or something.
Like we were at Link's funeral.
It was so funny.
Yeah.
It was so, so funny.
Anyway guys, thank you so much for our Devil May Cry 4.
We'll get to Devil May Cry 5.
Did I hear someone say it's not as long of a game?
Or...
Good job on beating another DMC game.
Great way to start the weekend.
Let's rock!
DMC 5 is still 20 missions.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'd rather decide when to do it because...
My...
I'm gonna start getting pretty busy here.
I don't want to put it off for so long.
Maybe I just get straight into it then.
How many streams was this?
5?
Wait, I did change that, right?
That is the correct number.
That is the correct number, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So 5...
1...
2...
3...
4...
Okay, maybe I will just start it next week then.
Personally, DMC 5 doesn't feel so long.
Because...
Basically, I don't like to start games and then...
Like, I'll be going to Japan and also going to...
Like, I have a whole lot of stuff planned in May and June.
So...
It might be better if I just start it next week.
So that I have extra time if...
You know, some people are saying it might be a little bit more difficult.
So if I...
Have extra time...
To get through it, it might be good.
Take your time, hope to see you soon in the future.
If you leave mid-May, you'll have plenty of time.
It's probably going to take as much time as 4.
Okay, that's not bad then.
So...
Should be okay then.
Could do two streams a week.
If it comes to that, I will.
I think we'll be alright.
I think so.
Yeah, I think we'll be okay.
Yeah, I will be going back to Japan next month.
Not sure yet if I want to stream while I'm there yet or not.
It's about a week and a half, I think, that I'll be gone.
And it's all for work.
All work.
In fact, there's a lot going on.
There's a lot going on on that trip.
For very cool, fun stuff that you'll see in the future.
While I'm waiting for you, I guess, I'll go check JPEGDAWG.
What could be happening?
Like I said, I might bring my set up so I can stream.
Even just a couple times while I'm over there.
Since it's less for play, I'll be in the worker's mindset already.
I'll be in the content mindset.
And since my last trip to Japan was way more for vacation...
Tiny monitor time.
We'll see.
Perfect for DMC.
Anyway, this is so much fun.
I'm actually so hungry, so I'm gonna go eat.
Maybe I'll go get some pizza.
Thank you guys for DMC4!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This is so much fun!
And I will see you guys probably next week for DMC5!
No more pizza, but I didn't get to eat my last pizza.
Well, I ate a couple bites.
It's too difficult to eat.
Otsubito!
Itterasshai!
Thank you everyone!
Byebye!